[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
enlightenment itself however which
reminds faith of the opposite aspect of
its separated moments is just as little
enlightened about itself it has a purely
negative attitude to faith so far as it
excludes its own content from its purity
and takes that content to be the
negative of itself if therefore neither
recognizes itself in this negative and
the content of faith nor for this reason
does it bring the two thoughts together
the one which it puts forward itself and
the on the one to which it opposes the
first sense it does not recognize that
which it condemns and faith is directly
its own thought it is itself in the
antithesis of the two moments only one
of which that is in every case the one
opposed to faith it acknowledges but
separates the other from the first just
as faith does consequently enlightenment
does not produce the unity of both
Azzurri unity that is as the notion but
the notion comes into being for it of
its own accord in other words
enlightenment finds the notion there
merely is something given for in itself
the realization of pure insight is just
this that insight whose essence is the
notion at first becomes for itself an
absolute other and repudiates itself for
the antithesis of the notion is an
absolute antithesis and then out of this
other nough succumbs to itself or to its
notion but enlightenment is only this
movement it is the still unconscious
activity of the pure notion and activity
which though it does arrive at its
object takes it to be another and to
does not know the nature of the notion
that is that it is the undifferentiated
which absolutely sunders itself as
against faith then insight is the might
of the notion insofar as it is the
movement and the relating of the moments
lying asunder in its consciousness a
relating in which there contradiction
comes to light herein lies the absolute
right of the authority which in Scitex
sighs over faith but the reality on
which it exercises this Authority lies
just in the fact that the believing
consciousness is itself the notion and
therefore itself acknowledges the
opposite aspect which insight puts
before it insight therefore it retains
its right as against faith because it
makes valid in faith what is necessary
to faith itself and what faith possesses
in itself
paragraph 565 is a rather long one and
there is a lot going on in there again
we're still dealing with this dialectic
between enlightenment or insight and
faith and as we saw just in the previous
paragraph Hegel says that that faith is
at a disadvantage one that he's noted
several times in relation to
enlightenment or insight where we're
really the the initiative is is going to
be on historically but one of the
reasons for that is that the moments of
faith which compose it's its organic
unity turn out to be able to be brought
into contradiction they are implicitly
in contradiction with each other so long
as faith remains faith and we're gonna
see that charted out a little bit more
in the paragraphs yet to come so that
that's a starting point and and Hegel
says here to begin this paragraph
enlightenment which reminds faith of
this opposite aspect of its separated
moments right enlightenment which is
showing faith to contain some at least
tensions or really quite quite frankly
contradictions within itself he says is
also unenlightened about itself so it's
critical but it's insufficiently
critical we've seen this discussed
already enlightenment at first has a
kind of advantage in being content less
in looking at faith which has
determinate content and saying oh that
determinate content that you're you're
working with is really just picture
thinking you're portraying the absolute
or God or the divine as something finite
something condition something that is
essentially a human projection and we're
not doing that we're not doing that
because we're not doing anything other
than look
what you're doing and saying no no no
that can't be right
and then the question that that faith
can can respond with an Enlightenment
actually has to ask itself is okay what
are you bringing to the table other than
complaints and criticisms what are you
bringing that's actually positive and
we've talked in the previous paragraphs
about some of the positive content of
enlightenment here Hegel is saying
enlightenment is not yet sufficiently
self reflective he says it has a purely
negative attitude to faith insofar as it
excludes its own content from its purity
and takes that content to be the
negative of itself so what is that
content who does that content belong to
I think we have to read what's going on
here in a double way there is the
content that faith not only has to
contribute but but consists in it brings
out it is right there you so to speak on
its sleeve it doesn't have to be you
know looked for faith already has a
content but as we saw enlightenment
itself has a content and so there is
indeed a kind of latent contradiction
within enlightenment itself insofar as
it's this critical attitude towards any
sort of determinacy isn't even calling
the absolute avoid a kind of determinacy
isn't the reduction of religion to the
useful a kind of determinacy isn't the
attention to the entire realm of
sensuous being through a new more
enlightened more sophisticated form of
sense certainty isn't that content isn't
that something determinate that
enlightenment then would have to look at
and apply the same sort of criteria that
it's applying to faith it doesn't let's
put it this way dozen enlightenment have
to take account of its own tendencies
towards idolatry just as much as
diagnosis within faith and the answer is
yes but enlightenment is not yet doing
that why isn't it doing that
well Hegel gives us the answer to that
in the rest of this paragraph it's not
sufficiently taking account of its own
connection to and similarity with faith
so he says it neither recognizes itself
in this negative in the content of faith
nor for this reason does it bring the
two thoughts together what are the two
thoughts the one which it puts forward
itself and the one to which it opposes
the first now again we could look at
that in two ways
maybe the one which it brings forward
itself is indeed faith but the picture
of faith not represented from the side
of faith faith giving its own
explanations about itself but
Enlightenment's viewpoint on faith and
there'd be a bit of let's call it irony
here understanding that it's not really
ironic but it's really just a
duplication going on in part because
what is faith accused of by
enlightenment of projecting a beyond the
absolute over there and keeping the
individual determinate human being over
here much the same way as the unhappy
consciousness did is that what's going
on here in this dialectic maybe it's
also enlightenment as we just said
trying to have its cake and eat it too
trying to be totally critical and yet
having a content of its own a content
that is supposed to trump that of faith
so he says it doesn't recognize that
what it condemns in faith is directly
its own thought how is that the case how
is the thought of faith we know that
faith is a mode of thought for Hegel
right it's going beyond culture it's not
the same thing as just the unhappy
consciousness or
the religion that we looked at earlier
in the spirit section it's it's thought
that goes beyond the world it's pure
thinking in a certain sense is that
something that insight or enlightenment
is producing since it does not recognize
what a condemns and faith is directly
its own thought he says it is itself in
the antithesis of the two moments
antithesis here being gig andand not gig
and shun its object sorry the antithesis
here is this this this opposition
between the two and it's a you know
placing them in a sort of not quite
contradiction at you know the term here
is not as strong as Vitas rook right the
antithesis is also going to turn up
within the notion in this paragraph
again so what what does Hegel have to
say he says doesn't recognize that it is
that that is enlightenment is in the
antithesis of the two moments what are
the two moments insight and faith only
one of which he says in every case the
one opposed to faith it acknowledges
what's going on here what is Hegel
talking about here does this make sense
it does again we have to revert back to
thinking about this enlightenment
creates a picture of faith it creates
its own imagination of what faith is up
to what faith consists in we saw a much
earlier that there's these three moments
of faith as faith understands itself and
then we have the moments of
enlightenment understanding those very
moments and understanding it in a
very different way which seems to
enlightenment to get at the real heart
of the matter it tells faith what faith
is really up to but we saw that faith
can respond and say you've missed some
things here insofar as enlightenment is
critiquing faith
it's critiquing something that is its
own projection onto faith it can never
truly be fair to faith and treat faith
as a genuine equal or partner so long as
it is misconstruing it but that is of
the very nature historically of the
Enlightenment so you know we see for
example the modern condemning the
pre-modern
as being superstition and not you know
therefore for that matter not actually
looking at what was going on say during
the dark ages reading some of the
literature investigating whether the
dark ages were truly as dark as they are
represented or whether the roots of the
Enlightenment didn't come out of those
pretend dark ages the high middle ages
for example the Renaissance coming out
of that so he goes on and he says it
separates faith and enlightenment out
from each other it creates a sort of
division between them that faith can
also recognize faith will return fire
right but enlightenment is really the
one who's creating this absolute
division so he says it acknowledges this
and then he says consequently
enlightenment fails to do something
important what is the mission of
enlightenment here what is enlightenment
supposed to be doing
he says enlightenment does not produce
the unity of both as their unity that is
as the notion as the be good all right
the kind
that's so central to the Hegelian
dialectic enlightenment doesn't produce
this unity of the both of them as their
unity but the notion he says comes into
being for it of its own accord the
notion is going to come into being
whether enlightenment likes it or not
it's a question of whether enlightenment
actually grasps the notion adequately
not whether the notion adequately
presents itself to enlightenment
enlightenment has to do more work than
it's actually doing so he says in other
words enlightenment finds the notion
there merely as something given
something for honden right out there
ready to be picked up the way I pick up
this piece of chalk or use this truck
where I take it for granted
enlightenment takes the notion for
granted the my teaming takes the concept
for granted and thereby doesn't actually
realize it doesn't make it actual so he
says in itself the realization of pure
insight is just this that insight whose
essence is the notion that first becomes
for itself an absolute other and
repudiates itself this is what what goes
on with the Hegelian notion this self
and other those are really part of the
same notion they are really part of the
same fundamental dynamic I can't say
thing I was tempted to say thing there
but the the same dynamic system you
might say so he goes on and he says the
antithesis of the notion is an absolute
antithesis now the German doesn't
actually spell out absolute antithesis
it just says the the antithesis of the
notion is absolute but what is absolute
in that case well the antithesis so the
absolute here is what we've been
striving after isn't it that's what
faith was
aiming at what enlightenment said you
are mistaking faith you're thinking that
it's just some sort of you know thing
that you can wrap your head around or
some some you know Airy
you know ethereal beyond that you can't
really talk about you're just reverting
to a kind of mysticism let's substitute
a void of predicate in its place as a
more adequate concept we saw that's not
really an adequate concept at all right
nobody's actually grasping the notion
here and nobody's realizing the
antithesis that that's taking place so
it's important from the phenomenologist
perspective to bring that antithesis to
light so he says out of this other Ness
it comes to itself or to its notion and
notice what he says now
enlightenment is only this movement it
is the still unconscious activity of the
pure notion it is being harnessed by the
notion but rather than the notion being
a tool of enlightenment enlightenment is
a tool of the notion the the
consciousness of enlightenment is not
fully conscious there's some unconscious
element or dimension to it so he goes on
and he says this is an activity which
although it does arrive at its object it
takes it to be another and it doesn't
know the nature of the notion that the
notion is the undifferentiated which
absolutely sunders itself so it's the
undifferentiated which differentiates
itself into a dynamic system
enlightenment should grasp the fact that
in the notion it is harness to faith you
can't get away from faith it can't
purify the world of faith and have just
enlightenment in its place so he goes on
and he says as against faith insight is
the might of the notion insofar as it's
the movement and the relating of the
moments lying asunder and it's
consciousness or relating in which
they're contradictions come to light all
right the contradictions of the moments
of faith but
Lightman's should also be noting its own
contradictions as well as the
contradiction between itself and faith
so he says this is the absolute right of
the authority which inside exercises
over faith insight turns out to be a bit
mistaken about what its authority is it
would like to say well I'm pure reason
I'm not you know I'm I'm purifying
rationality of all this this drags of
religiosity and and its origins and
religious thinking let's get rid of all
that stuff or at least suspend it so
then we can turn it against the actually
existing faith being exercised in the
world and and maybe well we'll get rid
of that as well Hegel saying that's not
really we're the authority of
enlightenment is coming from he says
it's the reality on which it exercises
its authority lies just in the fact that
the believing consciousness is itself
the notion now isn't that an interesting
thing to say the authority for this side
of the equation an equation here in a
very metaphorical sense the attic
waiting across the antithesis the
becoming adequate to by way of becoming
the notion takes place through grasping
that faith is also central to the notion
so enlightenment if it does eradicate
faith it eradicate s--
what it needs in order to exist it
destroys it's rays own depth all right
so he goes on and he says therefore it
acknowledges the opposite aspect which
incites puts before it insight retains
its right as against faith because it
makes valid in faith what is necessary
to faith itself and what faith possesses
in itself so we see
as opposed to the previous paragraph
where it looked like you know
enlightenment really had the the upper
hand over faith because it could be
conscious of it could turn faith and its
moments against itself and say look
you've got these inherent contradictions
enlightenment is going to be what allows
faith to be realized fully as faith now
this is going to be a bitter pill for
many people of faith to swallow
especially in our modern times after
this dialectic has taken place but
that's the way that Hegel is
representing what is going on between
insight and faith in the time period of
the Enlightenment
at first enlightenment affirms this
moment of the notion that it is an act
of consciousness opposing faith that
maintains that the absolute being of
faith is the being of the believers own
consciousness qua self or that this
absolute being as a product of
consciousness to faith its absolute
being while it is possessed of intrinsic
being for the believer is also at the
same time not like an alien thing which
was just found in him no one knowing how
and whence it came on the contrary the
faith of the believer consists just in
his finding himself as this particular
personal consciousness in the absolute
being and his obedience and service
consistent producing through his own
activity that being as his own absolute
being enlightenment strictly speaking
only reminds faith of this if faith
roundly asserts that the in itself of
absolute being is beyond the activity of
consciousness but while enlightenment it
is true corrects the one-sidedness of
faith by bringing to its notice the
opposite moment of action in contrast to
being than it is being which faith is
alone thinking of here and yet does not
itself bring its own thoughts together
it isolates the pure moment of action
and asserts that the in itself of faith
is only a product of consciousness this
action taken in isolation and opposed to
the in itself is however a contingent
action and qua activity of picture
thinking is a creating of fictions
picture thoughts which possess no
intrinsic being and this is how
enlightenment regards the content of
faith but conversely pure insight
equally says the reverse in maintaining
the moment of other nests within it it
pronounces absolute being to be for
faith something which in no way concerns
consciousness lies beyond it is alien to
it and unknown the case is similar with
faith on the one hand it puts its trust
in absolute being and in doing so
obtains the certainty of itself on the
other hand for faith absolute being is
unsearchable in all its ways and in its
being unattainable
paragraph 566 continues this story of
the conflict and a really productive
dynamic between faith and insight or
enlightenment in this historical period
and we find that that faith is in the
process of learning more about itself
and about its relation to its own object
at the same time that enlightenment is
learning about itself in relation to
faith and of course both of them in
relation to the absolute and the notion
so Hegel says enlightenment affirms this
moment of the notion that it is an act
of consciousness right that the
consciousness is what is driving this
and he says opposing faith it maintains
that the absolute being of faith is a
being of the believers own consciousness
qua a self or that this absolute being
is a product of consciousness nothing
new here right absolute being God the
divine is really a projection of the
individual or we might say of you know a
social assemblage a consciousness
carried out within the society it's some
sort of projection of humanity outside
to a beyond and we attribute all sorts
of cool things to the absolute being and
in contrast to it we are nothing but
lowly worms right so enlightenment says
look that's what's going on faith that's
what you're in the business of doing so
he says to faith however it's the
absolute being well it is possessed of
intrinsic being for the believer is at
the same time not like an alien being
which is just found in him some sort of
ideas right no one knowing how and
whence it came
there's a more personal relationship
between the individual believer and what
is being believed in what what one has
faith in so he goes on and he says the
faith of the believer consists just in
his finding himself as this particular
personal consciousness in the absolute
being there's a bit more in that
sentence but let's pause there for a
moment the believer instead of simply
saying I'm gonna project this aspect of
myself everything that's good everything
that's you know essential out this way
the believer actually finds him or
herself within the context of the
relation to the absolute being as as
what how do they find themselves well
this is where we get to the very
interesting portion of this here Hegel
talks about something that should be
familiar to us now because he's talked
about it many times throughout the
phenomenology the domain of action and
in religion what does action consist in
many different things here he talks
about obedience and service obeying the
absolute being showing service of some
sort to the absolute being these are
things that people do this is how they
commit themselves this is how they live
out a relationship with the absolute
being faith you might say to paraphrase
something without works is dead faith
right an important letter there so we go
on and he says this obedience and
service consists in producing through
his own activity that being the absolute
being as his own absolute being
it's an appropriation it's a affiliation
of oneself with the absolute being now
this doesn't mean simply you know
projecting our wishes or desires onto
the absolute being and saying oh lucky
me I found them there or anything like
that because that something is demanded
some action some sacrifice is required
in this case and we're gonna see Hegel
talking about this again in terms of
mortification a few paragraphs from now
so he says enlightenment strictly
speaking only reminds faith of this if
faith asserts that the the in itself of
absolute being is beyond the activity of
consciousness enlightenment could be
doing the job of telling faith hey you
actually have a humanized divine you
actually have a divine that you can
relate to and he says so enlightenment
can correct the one-sidedness of faith
by bringing to its notice the opposite
moment of action in contrast to mere
being I'm not I'm using the word mirror
there Hegel doesn't say mere being but
action is what is dynamic in this
situation and being is just what is
thought what is being projected there
what is being left is in itself in this
case so he says enlightenment can do
this but enlightenment he says doesn't
bring its own thoughts together right it
isolates the pure moment of action and
asserts that the in itself of faith is
only a product of consciousness it's not
a product of we might say encounter of
engagement so he talks about
enlightenment looking at this action in
isolation he says this action taken in
isolation opposed to the in itself is a
contingent action and is an activity of
picture thinking the believer is engaged
once again we see forced along you know
imagination representation picture
thinking not as good as the concept but
as we just saw in the last several
paragraphs enlightenment doesn't have a
monopoly on the concept right the
concept is greater than enlightenment by
itself or belief by itself or faith by
itself so he says from the perspective
in light of enlightenment faith is this
contingent action a creating of fictions
picture thoughts which possess no
intrinsic being and this is how he says
enlightenment regard
the content of faith and then he says
but that can't be all that enlightenment
or insight really thinks he says pure
insight also says the reverse so we've
got a problem here enlightenment is
saying two things about faith which of
them is true which of them is actually
going to be the case well both of them
have to be true in a sense how's that
gonna happen well let's see what he says
in maintaining the moment of other Ness
which the notion has within it
enlightenment produces the absolute
being to be for faith something which in
no way concerns consciousness lies
beyond it is alien to it and unknown the
case is similar with faith on the one
hand it puts its trust in absolute being
and in doing so obtains a certainty of
itself on the other hand for faith
absolute being is unsearchable in all
its ways and then it's being
unattainable Hegel here is saying that
there's a double problem of trying to
have two thoughts about you know what
what the other is in this case that are
in some sense at least at this point
incompatible right so how is this going
to be reconciled well we're going to see
this happen a little bit in the next few
paragraphs and then a bit more in the
next section
you